yeah pretty good
everybody had good lunch alright so as
Jen mentioned my name is Angelina
Favreau I hail from Vancouver Canada as
opposed to Vancouver Washington which
I'm sure many of you are from I'm
Angelina Magnum on Twitter feel free to
say hi for example if there's something
that I covered in the talk that you have
a question about or if you happen to
have some mobile inch cases that you
think I might find interesting
I'm more than happy to talk to you about
those things so Mobile's a thing it's
pretty important thing it just kind of
like throw some media queries into a
page and then you're basically done
right basically need to focus on maybe
one browser two browsers that's it okay
so there is a big problem I think with
mobile development and that's that
actually there are a lot of really good
tools but later in the talk you'll
actually see why this is a problem and
my personal problem is that no one tool
actually solves all of my problems for
me when I'm doing mobile application
development or mobile website
development depending on how you decide
to frame your paradigm of development so
in my mind whenever I'm dealing with CSS
there are two types of debugging that
I'm dealing with layout debugging or I'm
dealing with performance debugging those
are the things I care about Louis and
when I'm thinking about debugging tasks
i compartmentalize them into one of
those two things it's not always black
and white
but for now let's pretend it is so today
I'm going to talk to you about a little
bit to do what I do for my workflow when
I'm developing a mobile responsive
website in the past I worked at a spoke
shop in Vancouver where I did mobile
applications for the web and also for
native and then when I originally joined
Mozilla I was working on Firefox OS and
so I actually helped developers one on
one take their their applications which
were a largely responsive web
applications and then make them work on
these really low powered low memory
devices which are being shipped across
the world
to other nations to ideally give people
a smartphone experience you know where
they would have otherwise purchased a
feature phone for
kind of about the same price point and
so this talk is sort of a collection of
my tips and tools that along the way I
learn from other people and other
companies that do a lot of mobile
application development things that I've
had to like bash my head against the
wall at 2:00 in the morning trying to
figure out because I really wanted to
help someone or ship my own thing and
I'm hoping that this talk gives people
who are less familiar with mobile
websites you know kind of a quick place
to go for some easy tips and for those
of you who are a little bit more
seasoned with mobile development I hope
you learn about some cool tools as well
so for a manageable workflow I think the
really key thing is to get your layout
right early and in order to do that you
need to first think about who your
target demographic is now of course
we're at this lovely place called
Florida which is the United States of
America and I'm from Vancouver Canada
and so a lot of us here are probably
from North America and so we probably
have a very North American North
American centric view of things
of course North America is not the
entire world if you're in South Africa
it's likely that you could be using a
blackberry Symbian or a Nokia device or
and probably under it as well and you're
actually most likely to be using Opera
Mini as a browser or maybe Mobile Safari
if you're here in North America you're
probably most likely to be using you
know mobile safari stock Android 2.3
Browser
yes 2.3 we'll get to that in a moment um
and of course Chrome for Android Firefox
for Android if you're in China you might
be using blackberry Symbian Android
Nokia series 40 or you might be using
the official Chinese government
operating system yes that's right they
designed their own operating system
spork Mandarin have not previewed it
myself this was this was news to me if
you're in Venezuela you're probably
running Android or Firefox OS and it's
likely that you could be using the stock
Android 2.3 browser as well and so this
really just goes to show that you're
probably you know how to put it you
can't always predict who your market is
going to be it's really nice to think
that I am making a page for people that
are like me in North America and that's
probably true and maybe that's where you
get most of your traffic but why would
you necessarily exclude customers from
other regions by just not catering to
the devices that they use or the
browsers that they use for example I
mean as far as products go the social
network Orkut was a bomb in North
America Brazil totally loved it
my friend Jenn Fong did a website called
neat spaces where it takes like a little
clip of you as an animated gif and like
puts it it's like IRC meets snapchat
basically and one day suddenly a whole
bunch of press French 20-somethings
loved it and the thing is like people
didn't necessarily think that that was
going to be their target market but if
you're especially if you're selling
something why would you turn down any
market whatsoever so I encourage you
that when you're considering your target
demographic to not totally be North
American centric that being said I know
the people there will probably care the
most about iOS and Android and so those
are largely what we're going to talk
about today but please consider going to
other markets and other browsers so the
first thing of course was you know try
to figure out your target demographic
because that will help you decide what
your target devices and browsers are
maybe you know you're targeting iOS 6 up
and particular subset of iOS devices
maybe you're targeting a particular
subset of Android devices maybe you have
a lot of enterprise clients that happen
to be using blackberry and you need to
use blackberry hopefully not using web
fonts which we learned in the last talk
so that's a very important consideration
and deciding the target devices and
browsers are really important because
they will frame how your website is
created based on the constraints that
they have so the next thing and people
are usually into like their intuition is
that I want to start designing stuff
right okay so I know who I'm designing
for I know what viewports I'm designing
for I'm gonna hop right into Photoshop
perhaps and I'm gonna make some assets
no bad don't do it I really recommend
prototyping in your browser use a little
bit of structural HTML and some minimal
CSS to kind of get the layout right and
actually don't open Photoshop yet try
and avoid using Photoshop until you
really are at the last stages of needing
that visual look and feel you can put in
place holder content using a lorem ipsum
generator and of course using some dummy
cat images which I insist are the best
content placeholders for images but
don't worry about all the visual look
and feel because what I've noticed that
vellum developers will do when they're
finding stuff is they'll get really hung
up on making like the rounded edges and
drop shadows look really good but
they'll ignore till the last possible
minute layout issues which would have
been a lot easier to debug if they had a
lot less CSS to deal with so actually I
recommend prototyping in your browser
don't open Photoshop yet back in come
later and you want to be designing
inside the browser with these contextual
constraints of the devices and the
viewports that you're interested in kind
of like when an artist picks a canvas
right and artist picks a canvas and
everything they put on the composition
of that canvas that format is
constrained by the canvas and the same
is true for any kind of development or
composition that we're creating on the
web for people to look at similarly when
you're selecting things to use as
placeholder content make sure that they
are proportional to what you would
expect in the final product what I mean
by this is if you're doing something
that's a blog and you expect the content
to vary a lot make sure that your
placeholder content as you develop your
layout varies a lot if you're doing a
really targeted product placement on a
landing page and the measurement seemed
to be just right to get like you know
it's like a spotlight coming in on your
fancy product and there's like a drop
shadow behind it pick something that
roughly reflects that as well now this
may seem really odd aren't really
obvious to some people in the audience
but I can't tell you the number of
people who have come to me trying to
debug a layout issue only to drastically
change the layout before production and
reintroduce new layout issues so content
shapes design so the thing that I like
to use when I'm working on stuff first
actually is the responsive design view
in Firefox and that's actually not just
because almost like here it's actually
not just because I work for Mozilla I'll
explain why in a sec because in chrome
there's actually a device emulator as
well I think for the early stages of
design that the Firefox responsive
design view is an excellent tool and
what you should be using when you start
getting closer to device to device
testing I think that Chrome's device
emulator is what you should be using and
I'll explain that when we get to get a
little bit further so if we pop over to
oh gosh this is so tiny on my screen
hold on here oh god no it's good it's
beer come back
okay hold on a sec here oh no no okay
this is the least fun part of the talk
okay let's just come out of full screen
mode for a second here you can laugh
it's totally okay all right so we're
looking at the J s comp website I was
originally named as a CSS comp one but
it's a single page and it's actually
beautiful and I really couldn't it pick
on it but there are some things we can
poke around with in the J's comp website
which we'll do in a moment here
so if you're unfamiliar with responsive
design view and the Firefox dev tools in
the lower right corner there's this
little box and it looks kind of like a
rectangle in a rectangle that apparently
means responsive design view and what
happens when you click it is it brings
up a number of buttons and it will
resize your viewport to be to represent
the kind of device that you're looking
for and from the drop-down here we have
a number of different sizes but what I
like about this when comparing it to say
the Chrome emulator is I actually like
that there's these little sliders on the
size because when you're designing for
mobile viewports you kind of don't want
to design with absolute dimensions in
mind there's a lot of variation in how
different devices and browsers actually
you know deal with viewport dimensions
and it can be a really big headache so
you might have some variation between
all these devices and I sort of look at
it as like you want it you know I want
to target 320 by 480 ish and for those
of you who are you know not native
English speakers the suffix ish
expresses a degree of insert of a degree
of uncertainty so when I say I want to
be 3 you know 3 3:20 ish I wanted to be
about that wide but what I like to do
when I'm designing is actually just kind
of fiddle around with this side bar and
just see how my text reflows so I can
figure out really sensible font
breakpoints for my media queries so
that's pretty awesome and then this
actually just came to me last week
because we got this eyedropper tool
right who hears use colorzilla yeah and
then there's equivalent plug-ins for
Chrome it's like that so we got this
awesome
color picker tool in Firefox which on
its own is really not that interesting
the thing that I found myself using it
for
more than an actual color picker was
using it to inspect layout issues and
being able to inspect JPEG artifacts and
stuff like that so actually this thing
ends up being really really helpful for
someone like me who has a terrible
terrible eyesight and like we won't see
that stuff and someone else looks that
they're like what's wrong with you and
I'm like I'm blind
not even a joke and so I actually find
that that's actually pretty helpful too
now if we pop over into Chrome I've got
this little panel that when you enter
the dev tools and press escape are right
down here on the left you'll see there's
some tabs for emulation and also for
rendering which we'll talk about in a
bit so if I click emulate with this drop
down selected here for Apple iPhone 5 I
press that button it resizes the should
resize the viewport let me try
refreshing it it's a little bit buggy so
I think this is a really awesome tool
and it shows a lot of potential one of
the reasons why I'm using the responsive
design view is because I don't have to
refresh the page every time I change the
dimensions whereas I find with this tool
I have to although that couldn't go away
because I think there's there's you know
work that's gonna happen on it and so I
don't yeah I don't like having to do
that nobody likes spamming refresh
that's why we have like auto reload for
a region and stuff like that so so this
is actually pretty good tool like if you
prefer being in Chrome I think this is
also excellent and they give you a lot
of great customization option options so
you can select from the the drop-down
one of these presets or you can go into
the screen user agent and all that and
select something that's specific one of
the other things I really like is that
they do like they do let um you late the
device pixel ratio so if you're serving
up a version of your site that has
higher resolution assets for high pixel
ratio and devices like the iPhone 5 and
such you can actually spoof that here
which i think is pretty great alright so
so right after you start to bugging your
layout stuff whether it's with the
responsive design view or using Chrome's
device emulator I actually encourage you
at that point still before you get any
of your assets into your document to
start testing on devices debug that
layout stuff early really really trust
me on this because later on once you've
added all your assets and you're trying
to figure out
something doesn't look right you're
gonna have to go through all that CSS
that you've written since this point
which I'm warning you about and and deal
with that and we're going to talk about
remote debugging and on devices a little
bit towards the end in the meantime
we're actually going to talk about we're
going to talk about some cross browser
issues and the major ones that I've run
into so again start testing on devices
you know do not pass go do not collect
$200 do not do do not do anything else
don't be tempted and lured in by the
seductiveness of working in Photoshop so
it's really really fun I like it too
because it will get frustrating from
here there will be lots of surprises and
usually they have to do with
cross-browser and cross-device issues it
was really funny when I was making this
talk I wasn't sure how much time I
wanted to spend on this until I found
myself spending a lot of time on this
which i think is really how you describe
any sort of cross browser cross device
issues this is the least fun part of
making stuff on the web although for a
few people out there who I don't know I
consider the masochist they seem to get
a great deal of pleasure out of it so
you know a long time ago actually not
long ago enough we had this browser that
everybody disliked called Internet
Explorer 6 now to Internet Explorer is
credit newer versions of Internet
Explorer actually really awesome the
latest versions have some really awesome
performance profiling tools in them and
I'm not going to be the first or last
person to say this but Android 2.3 is
the new ie6 and I've got to check the
sphere of some common pitfalls because I
found that when people were coming to me
with applications and web pages that I
actually didn't have a lot of problems
with most other browsers it's just that
this one I had a huge headache with and
it's a pain in the butt it's a bug for a
lot of different reasons the thing is I
mean we're Android 4.1 now at four point
four four point and audience
so Android four points on thing and we
still need to support two point three
from browsing around the web and doing
their research on this talk and also
speaking to some mobile application
companies in Vancouver who have much
more experience than I do on this it's
really unclear to me at how many people
are actually still using Android 2.3
some numbers put it at 25% some numbers
put it at 15% it's still a significant
portion of the market that you might
care about and so you should probably
support Android too
three however it is definitely a pain so
for example the first one is that
position fix basically just doesn't work
well at all on Android 2.3 and actually
it turns out that position fixed it
doesn't really work that great on iOS in
general too so stay away from a fixed
position if you can in your layout and
you will save yourself a whole lot of
headaches now the interesting thing
about position fixed is that people
figured out this little interesting hack
called back face visibility:hidden and
there are different variations of it
people will apply this to various divs
and elements that they want fix
positioning on they'll apply it to
elements that apparently they want
better scroll performance on and I know
that Paul Irish is here he'll be talking
more about scroll performance later
today so I don't want to talk about that
too much
and you'll also see that sometimes the
add perspective and sometimes they add
like transforms to it and the premise
behind this is that for these screens
like WebKit and blink and particularly
can promote elements that have these
qualifying properties to their own layer
so you can get improved performance of
these elements on older Android devices
now it can end up being a problem though
sometime if you overuse this and it's
not a blanket solution if you don't have
enough virtual RAM you can end up with
worse performance and the transfer of
the work from the CPU to GPU can
actually take a performance hit as well
and so actually the jury is out on this
one for me I would love to actually talk
to more people because I've done that
and we still kind of didn't agree like
for example I went and talked to a bunch
of people at MOBA Phi lo-fi as a company
in Vancouver I pop in there now and then
and talk to them about mobile stuff
because that's what they do all day
every day and they were like Angelina
back face visibility no huge performance
problems it's not worth it we would deal
with websites where people use it all
over the place and apparently using it
multiple times can cause huge
performance problems but if you search
for problem or even if you search for
solutions to the problems of position
fixed on Android and respectively iOS
you will find this as the recommended
solution in different variations of this
sort and also sometimes in relation to
scrolling performance because you know
pushing on to the GPU can theoretically
make it more responsive so your mileage
may vary on this one I don't want to
like hands-down recommend this I want
you to use this judiciously and make up
your own mind
so yes it can cause more performance
issues and then it solves so if you're
an Android 2.3 using min height max
height min with max width they behave
inconsistently I've noticed that min
width and Max width will behave pretty
good but min high to max I like don't
even bother
they just won't stretch the way that you
think they will and it's really annoying
so just avoid those if possible
overflow:auto nope just don't use it
sometimes it kind of works and then you
actually the time is that it kind of
works you'll have a container and the
text will overflow but then kind of be
cut off in a weird way and then nobody
can read it so just just don't just stay
with overflow:auto so yeah just don't
use it and the z-index now z-index is
another one that comes up a lot it has a
lack of respect for absolutely
positioned elements which is really
annoying because often with mobile
designs you want to have a sticky header
at the top that you'll absolutely
position sometimes and I don't really
like this one websites will have little
tabs on the side that you can click on
that are social or contact things and so
I think the absolute positioning is
actually a pretty important thing for
mobile in this respect considering how
people use it however it turns out this
is actually very easy to easy to set
just make sure that you add a z-index on
the body tag and make sure that that is
set well to zero and then all the other
index elements will stack on top of it a
lot of the time people will just give
something as the index but not you know
think that they want to have a z-index
beneath that element it's something that
just kind of works out of the box and
other browsers but here this is the easy
fix for it so if your rosy index
problems I'm solutioning this isn't the
trick for you this one weird trick so
the other caveat is ms are poorly
supported and M's are kind of the
cornerstone they will think they're like
the gold standard unit that people use
for a responsive design I guess
percentages and M's that I probably see
the most and they're kind of janky you
can still use them but it'll be
frustrating for you Remz don't even
think about it now interesting thing
though I found out that the X unit is
supported so if you want to start
designing in X units then hey your
problems are solved so I don't know if
that's really gonna you know not really
know this information is gonna spur an
entire design paradigm shift but if you
are targeting Android 2.3 maybe you
consider using a slightly different unit
of measurement
gradience nope nope not on Android 2.3
don't even try it
they're not there which is you know
there's not really the best-performing
property anyway which we'll get to in a
little bit so when we go to iOS however
the interesting thing about the iOS
market share for browsers is that about
right now but 80 to 90 percent of people
are on iOS 7 and it wasn't released that
long ago I mean Apple they pester people
like I just plugged it I've got an
iPhone amongst other devices and I
plugged that thing in and every time I
swear like every couple days that wants
me to upgrade to a new version and so I
do because I don't wanna be pestered
anymore and this actually really works
because there's only about ten or ten
maybe fifteen twenty percent if we fudge
those numbers left of s6 users which is
really great because it means that we've
got this this really forward-thinking
set of people that are using newer
features that we want to sign with note
that at media queries and give portrait
dimensions even after rotating to
landscape which is a complete pain in
the butt position fixed also buggy even
on iOS 7 also very annoying
now flexbox is something that too I
think most developers is kind of a bit
of a godsend right I mean like it just
seemed really great to be able to
express things and proportions and have
the browser figure out the rest however
it's been through several iterations of
declaration I suppose and several
several iterations and the spec and so
there are a number of different
declarations Chris coil of CSS tricks
recommends that you use this declaration
and the order matters because the
display property is not prefixed here so
if you're ever using flexbox this is the
magic incantation that should work on
any CRO any firefox opera 12 plus I
think ie 10 plus C ie just does not have
really great flex box support but we're
talking about mobile so who cares and
Android should work on should work on
those two i'm firefox and chrome on
Android which are browsers that are not
as popular as mobile safari and 2.3 and
actually 2.3 and then chrome on Android
since you know Google introduced that is
in kind of gaining and two point three
is slowly waning both Firefox and Chrome
own and err
are pretty close to their counterparts
or identical to their counterparts on
desktop when it comes to the rendering
engines inside so you shouldn't have a
whole lot of problems with those I
certainly don't which is great because
by that point I'm really really tired
and I just kind of want to move on so
everyone else has educators to like if
you do have to ship on blackberry if you
do have to ship on opera Opera Mini
there are lots of those these two your
resources corks mode or which has been
around for a long time and I'm sure many
of you're familiar with is great but
this particular github repo from scott
jill has a tracker of basically people
filing device specific issues and
inconsistencies and that is also a
really excellent resource so if your
layout is decent by this point then I
think that it's time to consider
performance and you want to use this
point when your layout is mostly decent
between browsers and sort of your
baseline because as soon as you start
adding really really nice stuff like
graphics and web fonts you're adding
HTTP requests overhead and such so I
would use this as your baseline for
performance and as you add various
things to your page to enhance your
content you want to be comparing
constantly to make sure that you're not
doing something that gives you like a 15
Meg
I'm super into Sailor Moon by the way
like you really need to know that and if
you go to the Sailor Moon official
website because they're releasing a new
a new series soon I was like wanting to
inspect it because I felt like some
stars and full mystical and stuff I was
like oh this is really really cool but
it was the only page I've ever been to
in years where every page had a loading
spinner and the page weight was
something like 15 Meg's and even on
mobile it was like it was really heavy
so I was like man I love Sailor Moon but
not that much so a crash verse and a few
performance problems for for mobile
selector and property performance now
browsers are fast so I don't want you to
like labor over your selectors and your
properties like tryin to hyper optimize
them the browser will say take care of
stuff for you so browsers are fast
except for when they're not and
generally the rules of thumb that I've
found are stay away from the star
selector just avoid it if you can stay
away from really really long class names
because you're gonna have to let go
through lots of trees to find what
you're looking for
border-radius big performance culprit
box-shadow
also a performance culprit although
border-radius seems
to actually do worse transform
specifically rotations will kind of give
you some genki genki performance as well
and also check your preprocessor output
if you take a look at this top example
and you take a look at the bottom
example can anybody in the audience tell
me what the problem is with what's
generated in the bottom example what's
that someone said something about i7 ok
so yeah so the issue with what's
generated on the bottom is that it's
created this class where it's actually
going to go through all of the all of
the tree 4 steps in order to find out if
anything applies to or is going to apply
to it is 7 so we'll go through all of
this tree and the thing is the ia7 rule
might not apply to any of those things
in the page so we don't actually need
that now CSS coverage analysis is pretty
important because the fastest rule is
one that doesn't exist so if you go into
chrome and we're looking at the and
we're looking at the word we hear audits
page and we run this happy little tool
that's scared of that and we look at
webpage performance it will actually
tell us hey remove these unused CSS
selectors and that's really helpful but
this has only run on one page so if we
pop over to Firefox and hop into here we
actually have this new tool that just
landed in nightly and if I go to see
here let's turn off the responsive
design view there's actually a developer
toolbar at the bottom where there should
be where are you oh no it's down there I
just can't see it all right okay oh and
it's super tiny for me
CSS coverage starts so we start the CSS
coverage tool little bar tells us that
it's running and we navigate to
different pages and what the CSS
coverage tool does is it aggregates all
of those pages and then when we hit the
X here it will actually go and we go
into gasps coughs CSS you'll actually
see some rules it's very hard to see but
they have a strike through them and this
is a little bit different to what you
would normally see the inspector and
then it's actually showing us rules that
tool has a reason to believe are not
used at all and could be removed safely
on the pages that we've just browse
however that may not be true because
some of these Styles might be applied
with JavaScript at some later point and
so we didn't go through every page so
for example the one that says curator I
know for a fact that one exists on the
about page so that's applied there and
then if we type a CSS coverage this nice
little pie chart which will tell you
these styles that are relevant before
the load event is fired and which aren't
and this means you can actually optimize
your pages a little bit about what I'm
going about to tell you is a little bit
counterintuitive if there are styles
that you absolutely need put them in a
style tag in your head and if their
styles that you don't need and their
Styles that you don't need take the link
tag and actually put it with your
JavaScript that you defer as well at the
bottom of your page now I know you want
to separate your structural stuff from
your presentation and so at some point
that sort of does break down but if you
can get away with it do it and do it
because you can actually get some
performance gains that way okay I'm
Brassica Lee running out of time so
let's blow through this right so the
fastest rules one that isn't there when
you get to the very last stages of
production go through and try and remove
the stuff that is cruft from maybe your
CSS framework like styles that are
unused and just do a general clean that
way one of the things that I like to do
is take all the styles that I apply with
JavaScript and put them in a CSS file
and then run a grunt task that like goes
through all the stuff except for that
CSS file and basically it takes out all
of the cruft for me that is a 1:1 method
that I recommend so we just did that one
awesome Network conditions you are only
as good as your worst case and not
everybody has really really fantastic
Network conditions and also if you
happen to be driving through the
countryside of Montana well hey maybe
your coverage isn't that great actually
it's pretty good now but on oh s X using
Charles or the network link conditioner
will allow you to spoof different
differing network connections
this is really great to see exactly how
progressively your page loads really
explicitly windows Charles and dummynet
and net limiter and Linux Charles so
basically use Charles it's great it's
like it's a couple bucks and I think
it's a really really great tool you can
also measure FPS which is a great way to
look at your performance for different
interaction animations
and scrolling chrome if you go back into
the tiny menu we were in has where we go
here there we go okay so we actually
have rendering we have an FPS meters so
as oh this is the thing so the one
caveat in that I don't like about this
right now is if I get out of Device
emulation I will have the FPS reader or
of FPS widget but if I'm in and the
emulation would I don't have the FPS
widget and I would really really want
that for mobile but there's a really
great FPS widget in chrome which is
really great for for testing at your
performance and in Firefox we have a
little tool that's going to be in the
profiler that will give you your lowest
FPS your highest fps and the average and
actually it's pretty important that your
FPS is stable and above about 30 FPS at
minimum rather than having to jump all
over the place like maybe sometimes at
60 and sometimes it's 20 if you can't
get it to stick at something consistent
it's it's not going to be great for your
end users so testing on devices so we
can wrap this all up right we want to
remote debug like pros because when we
get to this point after we've gone
through designing this thing and testing
it in the you know maybe in Chrome's
device emulation panel you want to
actually test on devices because that's
what matters one of the things I like to
do is set up a little local server and
then like navigate my device to it but I
don't get developer tools with that and
if something goes wrong it's not very
easy I mean if you've got a good eye you
can spot some layout bugs and that's
pretty fantastic so solution is just to
buy all the phones right yeah one
argument that I've been giving the
people though is actually to get your
hands on a Firefox OS device because
they're cheap and lots of device labs
have have them just because if anything
can run on there it will run everywhere
else they're not high powered devices so
if it runs there it will run everywhere
they're very cheap to buy Android 2.3
browser you're going to be using Winery
which is a script remote debugging tool
that injects you know inject some script
into your page and you get kind of like
a janky version of the Safari WebKit
tools but it's not fully functional it's
very frustrating so if you're still
trying to remote to bug on 2.3 godspeed
so if you're debugging Firefox or
Firefox for Android use Firefox bugging
Chrome for Android is Chrome yeah I see
a problem here the bugging mobile safari
okay finally as IO 6 we can do that with
safaris dev tools and I did learn that
there was actually a chrome bridge
although it was unclear to me exactly
how to do that and it didn't quite work
out of the box that I expected but it's
there so the problem here is that
everybody is in silos personally I think
that our tools should go where the web
is and that is everywhere and I don't
like the idea that I have to work in
silos to do all of my remote debugging
so I wanted to give you before I go a
little sneak peek into something that's
coming with the Firefox dev tools that I
think really will help solve some of
this problem for people and it is called
Project fever dream we like to name
things a little bit ridiculously
internally so it reminds us to change
the name so pop over here so what I'm
going to show you is our dev tools
connecting to Firefox we're just going
to change some text it says shared
knowledge that will change to to move
everywhere and then we'll change the
background to a color pink that we call
Paul Rose a pink Paul is a member of the
dev tools and he's well known for making
things stand out with this pink and then
we'll just go through and do a console
console alert so that we can see that
yes we are connected and it will say
hello from Firefox okay well that's
great we knew that Firefox would connect
to the Firefox dev tools and I apologize
for the quality here we just whipped
this up at the last minute we're doing
the same thing we're going to change the
text on there we're connected to Chrome
on Android with the Firefox dev tools
and we're also going to change the power
shape pink and do an alert but of course
what most people care about is the most
used market share and they care about
iOS and so right now we've worked hard
on that and made it so that you can
actually connect using the Firefox dev
tools that's hard to see it's an iPad
they're running Safari you can connect
and debug Safari which with much better
dev tools now than the Safari ones which
sorry Safari they just really really
stink
so we're gonna change the background a
polish a pink and everything works it
should say hello from Safari so this
feature unlike the ones that I showed
you today hasn't totally landed yet so
it's going to be coming if you're
interested in that then you can follow
me because I won't shut up about it and
also you can follow Firefox
tools on Twitter so that's it
Oh oh my god I totally forgot one really
important thing and it's totally amazing
okay so just like this one thing the guy
in the front row is giving me the
stink-eye so I know I'm supposed to be
done but I promise you that this is
helpful one thing that just landed
thanks to Heather Arthur who's here is
if you go into the style editor style
she is unhappy because it couldn't be
loaded that's cool go to a style editor
and we right-click on one of these style
sheets and we actually take a look over
on the right here you'll see that there
are actually media queries that are
highlighted if you're using the
responsive design view and resizing it
it will actually highlight which media
queries apply to your page and if you
click on them it will take you to those
media queries in your code and that is
the last thing I have for you today
thank you very much everyone